[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée avec au programme de
l'actualité et des infos pratiques et
des idées de sortie voici le programme
de ce 16 janvier
c'est l'une des mesures du gouvernement
pour faire face à l'inflation
l'indemnité carburant depuis aujourd'hui
il est possible pour les personnes
éligibles de faire la demande pour en
bénéficier sur le site des impôts
comment ça fonctionne qui est concerné
comment obtenir cette aide on fait le
point
tout au long du mois de janvier période
traditionnelle des vœux TV 78 reçoit les
maires de 50 ans en Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 dans
leur ville ce soir focus sur
Montigny-le-Bretonneux sobriété
énergétique hyper centre réouverture du
club le village ou encore Tour de France
à quoi faut-il s'attendre le nerf de la
commune Leroy Merker et notre invité
et puis le sport ils sont de retour sur
les terrains les Templiers d'Élancourt
débute leur saison le week-end prochain
à l'extérieur avant un premier match à
domicile ce sera le 28 janvier et nous
verrons quels sont les ambitions de
l'équipe en deuxième division de
football américain et on parlera de ce
sujet justement avec deux invités qui
sont avec nous en plateau Jordan Debra
bonsoir On dit deux bras ou de brasses
de bras deux bras très bien et en face
de vous il y a Alix Wemba bonsoir donc
tous les deux du club d'Élancourt des
Templiers d'Élancourt vous êtes le
capitaine de l'équipe senior Jordan et
vous êtes vous Alix le coordinateur de
la défense et je le disais la reprise de
la saison c'est le weekend prochain en
deuxième division casque d'or face au
léopard de Rouen ce sera un match à
l'extérieur est-ce que vous êtes
impatient de reprendre cette saison
Jordan toujours un patient de jouer au
foot américain de toute façon et un
patient de reprendre la compétition ma
passion j'imagine aussi de jouer ce
premier match à domicile ce sera dans
deux semaines le 28 janvier bah toujours
toujours impatient parce que c'est
retrouver nos supporters après une
longue trêve donc ça fait toujours
plaisir comment ça se passe ça se passe
bien ça suit son cours
dommage de préparation on est sur une
bonne dynamique on finit sur une
victoire le week-end dernier le groupe
est prêt motivé et on attend que ça
revienne comme il disait Jordan et on
fera le point sur vos ambitions en
deuxième partie d'émission et on fera
aussi le point sur l'ensemble des
résultats sportifs du week-end ce sera
avec notre journaliste Mickaël Elmi Doro
bonsoir Laurent Merker bonsoir vous êtes
vous le maire de la commune de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux également premier
vice-président de 50 ans en Yvelines en
charge de l'urbanisme et de
l'aménagement du territoire et vous
allez présenter vos vœux à vos habitants
c'est une tradition au mois de janvier
ce sera le 18 janvier donc 19 janvier
jeudi en vidéo pourquoi faire le choix
de faire des vœux en vidéo alors que
dans d'autres communes on tient une une
cérémonie de vœux on va dire un peu plus
traditionnelle écoutez vous l'avez
évoqué dans les titres vous avez parlé
de plein de sobriété et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est obligé de faire de
gros efforts face aux de l'énergie qui
ont augmenté de manière incroyable et
donc a dû demander à tout le monde de
faire des efforts sur la ville et à
partir du moment où je demande à tout le
monde de faire des efforts il faut que
je commence par moi c'est l'exemplarité
donc j'ai décidé d'annuler les vœux je
regrette un peu parce que on arrive à la
troisième année du mandat et j'avais
beaucoup de choses à dire mais écoutez
on va le faire sous une autre forme une
forme vidéo et les gens auront le temps
et le loisirs de le regarder comme ça et
de voir tout ce qu'on a pu faire et tout
ce qu'on compte faire aussi sur l'année
qui vient et les suivantes et on parlera
avec vous dans quelques instants des
grands projets les grands dossiers de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux pour l'année 2023
avec Nosy Régine rage de la rédaction de
tv78 bonsoir avec vous dans un instant
les informations du jour dans cette
édition aussi focus sur une expo photo
de pompiers pour célébrer l'amitié
franco-allemande et puis de la musique
avec l'interview de la Pieta l'artiste
sera en première partie de Skip The Use
le 3 février prochain à la Meuse à
Trappes mais avant tout cela coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
après la journée venteuse de ce lundi le
jour le plus déprimant de l'année le
Blue Monday la pluie est toujours le
froid demain mardi le matin à des
gouttes sont attendus sur la partie nord
et ouest du département il fera 2 degrés
dans l'après-midi il devrait même
pleuvoir sur tout le territoire
yvelinois côté température il fera à 3
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et
Versailles quatre degrés à Versailles ce
mardi à 17 janvier nous fêterons les
Roselyne
[Musique]
place aux informations du jour avec vous
Régine ralech et on commence avec notre
chiffre du jour oui Grégory notre
chiffre du jour est sans puisque c'est à
la vitesse de 100 km/h que des rafales
devant ont été enregistrés dans les
Yvelines cette nuit il y a eu 15
interventions liées aux intempéries et
ce matin mille foyers ont été privés
d'électricité le département était placé
en vigilance orange fond et cru l'alerte
a depuis été levée mais demain les
Yvelines seront de nouveau en alerte
jaune mais cette fois-ci neige et
verglas cette fois-ci une tempête que va
affronter le gouvernement celle de la
contestation sociale sur la réforme des
retraites cette semaine sera marquée par
la grève nationale jeudi 19 janvier de
nombreux syndicats se mobilisent contre
la réforme des retraites dévoilées par
Elisabeth borne mardi dernier plusieurs
secteurs se mobilisent le corps
enseignant le secteur de l'énergie de la
santé la fonction publique la police et
les transports on y reviendra dans la
semaine pour faire le point on continue
avec une manifestation à Achères qui
s'est déroulé hier dimanche oui ils
étaient plus d'une fontaine à se
manifester des habitants et des élus
sont venus dénoncer un projet routier
porté par le Conseil départemental des
Yvelines une route à quatre voies
reliant les départementales 30 et 190
ainsi qu'un pont entre les villes
d'Achères et de carrière sous Poissy
prévus fin 2023 les manifestants
craignent des nuisances sonores et des
pics de pollution on poursuit avec
l'image du jour une rencontre entre des
collégiens et des personnalités
politiques le collège Charles Péguy au
Chesnay Rocancourt organise en ce moment
des rencontres entre les élèves de
l'établissement et des personnalités
politiques le but est de transmettre les
valeurs républicaines aux jeunes ce
matin eu lieu la première rencontre avec
la députée de la troisième
circonscription des Yvelines Béatrice
Piron on écoute tout de suite les
échanges c'était des échanges de 13
enrichissants et pour moi aussi j'étais
impressionnée par le travail de
préparation qu'ils ont fait sur la
variété des questions j'ai renforcé mes
connaissances sur ce qui était une
députée j'ai hâte d'aller à l'Assemblée
nationale et de rencontrer vous avez
plein d'autres personnalités en
apprendre plus sur les valeurs de la
République et voir son point de vue
professionnel et personnel de des
valeurs
et cette expérience ne s'arrête pas aux
élèves du collège Charles Péguy puisque
des capsules vidéo seront disponibles
sur la plateforme de l'éducation
nationale et serviront aux enseignants
comme outils pédagogiques les prochains
rendez-vous auront lieu les 24 janvier
et 17 février les collégiens
rencontreront la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale Yaël Bron Pivet et
Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat et
on termine les informations du jour avec
les peluches du cœur une opération
solidaire organisée samedi 14 janvier
par le club de basket de Poissy ce
concept qui vient des États-Unis
consiste à lancer des peluches sur le
terrain pour que ces dernières soient
récupérées et redistribuées cette année
ce sont les enfants des familles
accueillies par les Restos du Coeur de
Poissy qui seront les bénéficiaires en
écoute Stéphane Lecordier le président
du club de basket de Poissy c'est une
oeuvre encore une fois qui a du sens
pour nous qui est importante qui est
solidaire on l'organise également avec
les élus avec la ville de Poissy les
gens du resto vous avez vu tout à
l'heure sont avec nous aussi présentes
voilà il y a une sportive solidaire pour
nous c'est important enfin tu fais
partie de l'ADN du club voilà pour cette
action solidaire on reviendra sur le
match de basket de Poissy dans les
résultats sports à suivre dans un
instant merci Régine pour ces
informations du jour et si vous aussi
vous êtes témoin près de chez vous d'une
information qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7 8 news
et Gabriel Gonthier nous a rejoint au
plateau bonsoir journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 l'Ariston du
gouvernement sur les prix à la pompe
n'est plus en vigueur et ce depuis le
1er janvier 2023 exit l'ancienne ristour
des places désormais à l'indemnité
carburant pour une partie des Français
les demandes peuvent être faites à
partir d'aujourd'hui quel est le
principe de cette indemnité alors
exactement Grégory déjà vous l'avez dit
l'Ariston ne des 10 centimes par litre
qui avait été mise en place l'année
dernière c'est fini mais depuis 9h ce
matin elle est remplacée par une
indemnité de 100 euros et ce est bien
pour faire face à la hausse des prix et
préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
Français alors elle est baptisée
indemnités carburant travailleur et elle
est en vigueur jusqu'au 28 février qui
sont les Français concernés alors
l'indemnité elle concerne les 50% des
ménages les plus modestes qui ont besoin
de leur véhicule pour aller travailler à
noter Grégory que ça concerne tous les
types de véhicules alors pour être
éligible il faut disposer d'un revenu
fiscal de référence inférieure à 14 700
euros en 2021 si si deux actifs dans un
fou si vous êtes deux actifs pardon dans
un foyer c'est le calcul des deux
revenus cumulés qui fait fois en
revanche l'indemnité elle va être versée
par personne et non parfois voyez donc
vous toucherez bien 200 euros et au
total c'est environ 10 millions de
personnes qui sont concernées par cette
aide et qui sera versée je précise une
seule fois il commence à se passe pour
la toucher est-ce que c'est automatique
est-ce qu'il faut en faire une demande
et bien non justement c'est pas
automatique sachez que vous devez en
faire la demande pour cela vous devez
aller sur le site mis en ligne par
impôts.gouv.fr si jamais vous n'avez pas
accès aux services en ligne vous pouvez
contacter le zéro 80600 229 vous devrez
ensuite remplir un formulaire en ligne
avec votre numéro fiscal votre numéro
d'immatriculation et une attestation sur
l'honneur indiquant que vous utilisez
votre véhicule pour aller travailler le
versement se fait ensuite directement
sur votre compte en banque on va parler
des actifs est-ce que les demandeurs
d'emploi sont également concernés oui
tout à fait les chômeurs qui ont besoin
de se déplacer pour rechercher un emploi
concerner Elisabeth borne la première
ministre avait affirmé en décembre 2022
qu'il pourrait se rapprocher de Pôle
Emploi pour faire la demande merci Gabri
pour toutes ces précisions on rappelle
un cette date vous avez jusqu'au 28
février pour faire votre demande
d'indemnités carburant Leroy Merker je
me tourne vers vous pour parler avec
vous des grands projets de l'année 2023
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux je le rappelle
vous êtes le maire de la commune alors
en ce début d'année on a commencé à en
parler tout à l'heure revient souvent un
mot dans la bouche de tout le monde
c'est celui de la sobriété énergétique
vous avez fait le choix de faire des
vœux en vidéo à Montigny justement pour
vous conformer à cette sobriété
énergétique et ne pas forcément
organiser de de cérémonie de vœux il y a
aussi un plan sobriété qui a été adopté
à Montigny fin 2022 que prévoit-il et
qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez de faire en
2023 sur cette thématique alors en fait
on a profité de la situation de la crise
énergétique pour
se questionner sur des des solutions qui
pourraient être trouvées à la fois dans
le très court mais aussi sur le long
terme parce que c'est la vertu des
crises c'est qu'elle pousse à un
changement plus rapide en général on
voit le télétravail et la
visioconférence avec la covid et là avec
ce qui se passe actuellement avec la
crise énergétique en fait on se
réinterroge sur toutes nos pratiques sur
l'usage de nos bâtiments donc les
mesures rapides qui ont été faites ça a
été de baisser la température dans les
équipements de fermer pendant un mois le
centre aquatique puisque c'est
l'équipement qui consomme le plus
d'énergie sur le sur le territoire de
Montigny ça a été aussi de regarder avec
toutes les associations et d'ailleurs
nous avions une réunion samedi matin
avec toutes nos associations culturelles
pour regarder ensemble l'utilisation des
locaux voir comment optimiser les
espaces de façon à pouvoir générer des
économies et un autre point important
qui sera présenté dans le budget qui
sera voté le mois prochain pour la ville
c'est aussi un emprunt que nous faisons
auprès de la banque des territoires qui
est un emprunt spécifique destiné à
pouvoir remplacer très rapidement tous
les séminaire que l'on peut avoir sur
nos équipements on a 70 équipements sur
la ville donc remplacer tous les
luminaires par des leds je te remets
installer des robinets thermostatiques
partout il en manquerait changer les
vieux radettes les grille-pains comme on
dit par des radiateurs plus performants
et ça vraiment ça c'est le très court
terme et puis derrière encore une fois
c'est réfléchir à tous nos usages mais
ça nous le faisons de manière collective
et concertée avec les associations qui
d'ailleurs sont
très forces de proposition dans ce
domaine là donc c'est vraiment un débat
très intéressant qu'on peut mener sur le
sujet pendant les grands dossiers de
2023 qui va voir le jour prochainement
on a l'habitude d'être sans doute on
avait l'habitude d'aller foulé les cours
de ce club de sport c'est le club le
village qui va réouvrir et qui a
bénéficié en plus d'une rénovation
thermique et aussi de nouvelles
disciplines qui pourront être pratiquées
au sein de ce club c'est ça alors sur la
réhabilitation thermique pour faire un
peu la suite du sujet que nous évoquons
là c'est vrai qu'on est dans une
continuité sur ce mandat puisqu'on a
déjà réhabilité deux écoles sur le
quartier des prés ainsi que la maison de
quartier Malraux et donc désormais c'est
le club le village
on espère une économie d'énergie de 60%
sur l'équipement et derrière un bâtiment
qui dans son fonctionnement c'est un
bâtiment qui datait des années 80 a été
complètement revu donc un confort pour
le usagers complètement différent à un
lieu d'accueil beaucoup plus sympathique
et des nouvelles disciplines nous avons
gardé le tennis nous avons gardé le
squash nous gardons le badminton mais
nous offrons désormais du foot en salle
du foot salle comme on dit et nous
proposerons aussi du PADL donc cette
activité de tennis sur des petits
terrains voilà des activités nouvelles
qui vont venir s'ajouter à ce que
propose la ville de Montigny désormais
nous restons dans les équipements
rénovés ou même nouveau alors en 2023 il
y a la rénovation thermique de la crèche
Comtesse de Ségur dans le quartier de
Saint-Quentin il y aura même la
construction d'une nouvelle crèche dans
le quartier de la Sourderie alors je
vais commencer par la nouvelle crèche
effectivement qui vient à la place de
l'ancienne école sa main sur laquelle
donc que nous avons rasé il y a quelques
années sur laquelle nous avons fait un
programme de logement et ce nouvel
équipement destiné à la petite enfance
qui lui aussi thermiquement sera
évidemment
extrêmement intéressant mais qui
présente des espaces qui sont très très
bien pensés pour accueillir nos enfants
donc c'est pour nous une capacité
d'accueil de 50 enfants qui qui se
créent sur la ville avec donc des
espaces qualitatifs des espaces
extérieurs aussi pour les enfants donc à
partir de la rentrée prochaine de
septembre prochain nous aurons un
nouveau lieu d'accueil pour la petite
enfance à Montigny-le-Bretonneux donc ça
c'est pour la nouvelle crèche et la
Comtesse de Ségur qui elle est une
crèche historique de la ville de
Montigny située dans le quartier
Saint-Quentin pas très loin d'ici cette
crèche là elle était effectivement
thermiquement
très dépassé et puis fatigué donc nous
avons décidé de la reprendre
complètement et de de la transformer
pour avoir une une crèche qui réponde
elle aussi à toutes les nouvelles normes
en matière d'énergie et non seulement
nous réhabilitons complètement la crèche
mais nous renaturons la cour de cette
crèche qui était entièrement bitumée
jusque là et qui demain proposera de la
vég et des espaces beaucoup plus verts
que ce que nous avions jusqu'à
aujourd'hui dans les cartons également à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il y a aussi
cette réhabilitation du centre sportif
Pierre de Coubertin le centre loisirs de
loisirs du Manet est-ce qu'il y aura du
concret cette année sur cette sur
Coubertin oui c'est déjà commencé
puisque nous avons nous sommes en train
de sélectionner le cabinet d'architecte
qui nous accompagnera sur cette
réhabilitation et puis il faut bien ça
savoir se rappeler que sur cette
réhabilitation nous sommes à la fois sur
les espaces intérieurs mais aussi sur
les espaces extérieurs c'est à dire
qu'on va refaire le terrain de foot
synthétique on va refaire la piste on va
proposer là aussi de nouvelles activités
avec du sport outdoor du street workout
s'appelle comme ça et puis sur
l'intérieur de l'équipement
effectivement là on va être plutôt dans
la phase administrative et tout le
travail préparatoire avant ses grands
travaux qui arriveront en 2024 ou 2025
pour le centre de loisirs du Manet
centre de loisirs du Manet là nous cette
année ça sera la phase administrative
c'est pareil tout le travail à la fois
pour préparer ce dossier puis en même
temps toute la recherche des subventions
parce que nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
plus que jamais avec la situation
économique de pouvoir chercher des
subventions donc c'est tout le travail
auquel nous allons nous appeler cette
année en 2023 sera aussi l'année du
lancement de grands travaux à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux avec
l'agglomération de 50 ans divine les
travaux de l'hypertentre autrement dit
tout le quartier autour de la gare et du
théâtre de Saint-Quentin avec donc le
début des travaux prévus cette année en
tout cas le début du chantier c'est
cette année oui alors là c'est un
aboutissement de toute cette phase
administrative dont je parlais pour les
dossiers précédents et bien nous
arrivons au bout cette fois-ci pour
l'hyper centre rappelez-vous on a
commencé en 2019 avec la concertation
des habitants du quartier et là
aujourd'hui nous pouvons prévoir un
démarrage des travaux en fin d'année
sachant que ça commencera un peu plus
tôt puisque nous avons déjà la
démolition de l'immeuble que l'on
appelle l'anneau rouge que l'on a vu à
l'image autour de la place de la gare
avec toute la reprise de la et
l'ouverture de celle-ci sur sur la ville
et puis ensuite évidemment on a l'avenue
du centre qui va être refaite dans un
premier temps avec la place Pompidou
puis nous referons tout le long du canal
et le bassin du quai Truffaut donc juste
à côté de la médiathèque donc là on est
sur un chantier qui va durer plusieurs
années on va faire un certain nombre de
réunions avec les habitants pour leur
expliquer un petit peu comment tout cela
va se passer parce qu'effectivement
comme nous sommes en centre-ville ça va
perturber un petit peu les choses mais
on comprend bien aujourd'hui l'enjeu que
ça peut représenter à la fois pour la
ville de Montigny mais aussi pour
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et pour le
département qui d'ailleurs va être très
présent à nos côtés financièrement sur
cette opération parce que c'est un enjeu
majeur pour le département des Yvelines
également donc ça c'est une véritable
satisfaction effectivement de voir ce
sujet aboutir et d'aboutir de cette
façon la thématique du handicap aussi
est centrale à Montigny-le-Bretonneux il
y a une semaine du handicap un chaque
année qui est l'un des rendez-vous
phares de l'année il y a la Fondation
aussi Anne De Gaulle qui va ouvrir une
structure d'accueil pour les personnes
en situation de oui absolument ça
c'était un souhait très fort que nous
portions nous venons comme vous l'avez
dit une politique très active sur le la
thématique du handicap mais nous
n'avions pas de structure d'accueil pour
personne en situation de handicap sur la
ville j'ai su en tout début de mandat
que la fondation de Gaulle cherchait un
lieu d'accueil pour sa structure et donc
j'ai proposé qu'il puisse venir sur mon
Tigny et donc les travaux vont démarrer
cette année et ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant là-dedans c'est que il y a
une démarche au niveau de la Fondation
Anne De Gaulle aujourd'hui complètement
nouvelle sur la prise en charge de ces
personnes qui sont des personnes
déficientes intellectuelles et qu'il
s'agit de complètement enfin d'intégrer
au mieux à la cité et donc ils vont
créer un Living Lab en plus du lieu
d'accueil un lieu de recherche
pour justement voir comment permettre
aux personnes en situation de handicap
d'accéder à la citoyenneté et je leur ai
proposé s'il y a un lieu où se joue la
citoyenneté dans une ville c'est bien la
mairie donc on y a un partenariat entre
nous pour de façon à pouvoir travailler
sur ce sujet là et voir comment mieux
intégrer encore ces personnes dans
l'avenir de grandes fêtes à venir aussi
pour la ville avant les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques en 2024 il y aura le 23
juillet 2023 à cocher sur le calendrier
puisque mon team Bretonneux sera la
ville départ de la dernière étape du
Tour de France donc la 21e et dernière
étape de l'édition 2023 qui s'élancera
du vélo de drone direction les
Champs-Élysées on imagine une exposition
très très importante pour la ville avec
ce rendez-vous très suivi et bien oui
c'est une très très belle surprise et
là-dessus je tiens à remercier
à Esso de nous avoir choisi et puis
évidemment le président du conseil
départemental pierre Bédié qui qui lui
aussi a pesé de tout son poids pour que
les choses puissent se faire de cette
manière
ça préfigure les Jeux Olympiques qui
arriveront en 2024 donc un grand
événement sportif festif extrêmement
populaire qui qui démarrera qui débutera
pour sa dernière étape sur Montigny
évidemment oui c'est une façon de donner
à avoir le territoire et ça c'est une
très très belle une très bonne nouvelle
et ça va être en lumière ce site
olympique le vélo de route nationale la
piste de BMX aussi est-ce que c'est un
rendez-vous qui se prépare déjà en 2023
ces Jeux Olympiques même si c'est
l'année prochaine en 2008 bien sûr et
nous les préparons déjà depuis un
certain temps on a commencé avec la
recherche des bénévoles nous avons mis
en place aussi tout un programme
d'activités d'animation il y a des
choses qui se sont déroulées au
Vélodrome par exemple mais nous faisons
aussi chaque année des découvertes de
sport au sein des écoles à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et puis nous
avons associé là aussi toutes nos
associations pour voir quels événements
nous pourrions mettre en place pour
sensibiliser la population parce
qu'évidemment pour que ce soit un beau
rendez-vous il faut que la population se
sente associée concernée par cet
événement et que nous n'ayons pas que
les gens qui viendront assister aux
épreuves sur le territoire tout dernière
chose si on reste dans ce secteur on va
dire du Vélodrome parmi les autres
grands projets il y aura le lancement
2023 d'études pour la réalisation d'une
passerelle piéton cycliste qui permettra
d'accéder à l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin absolument on est dans le
cas du RER vélo là donc c'est avec la
région Île-de-France et 50 ans en
Yvelines nous aurons ce ce vieux rêve
que nous avions
avec mon prédécesseur Michel Laugier il
y a quelques années de pouvoir créer une
passerelle qui permette d'accéder pour
les piétons et les cyclistes à l'île de
loisirs au dessus de l'autoroute et à
l'époque nous étions heurtés à des coûts
absolument prohibitifs et bien
aujourd'hui grâce à ce plan vélo
développé avec le la région nous avons
la possibilité de mettre en place cette
passerelle et donc demain nous aurons
une liaison supplémentaire pour aller
vers l'île de loisirs complètement
protégée donc énormément de projets sur
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et évidemment en
tant que mère j'en suis absolument ravi
parce que le nous avons un mandat un peu
particulier là je parle pour tous les
maires qui ont débuté en 2020 entre la
crise sanitaire et aujourd'hui la crise
de l'énergie et pour autant sur Montigny
nous arrivons à avoir des projets
enthousiasmants et qui vont redonner
encore de la dynamique supplémentaire au
territoire et pour terminer cet
entretien on passe à l'interview express
[Musique]
Laura Mercier je vais vous poser cinq
questions cinq questions qui nécessitent
des réponses courtes oui un nom un pour
ou contre parfois quelques explications
je vais vous demander de faire vos
explications sur 20 et 30 secondes ce
sera la seule exigence et on posera la
question à l'ensemble des maires 50 en
Yvelines qui vont venir en plateau sur
ce mois de janvier jusqu'en 2023 vous
augmentez les impôts locaux dans votre
commune non s'il y a des sur la
circulation certaines communes ont opté
pour la limitation à 30 km/h ce que vous
vous êtes pour ou contre une telle idée
nous l'avons déjà mis en place dans un
certain nombre de résidences oui depuis
longtemps donc peut-être une étendre à
Montigny ou rester travaillant là-dessus
avec les conseils de quartier oui mais
il faut qu'on fasse attention chaque
voie en fonction de son dimensionnement
et de son utilité doit avoir une vitesse
adaptée et donc on regarde ça il s'agit
pas de prendre une décision comme ça
grossir pour l'ensemble de la ville mais
bien d'être sur des choses qui répondent
aux besoins que l'on peut avoir de
circulation sur le territoire certaines
communes ont fait le choix du bio pour
leur cantine est-ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre l'obligation du Bio dans les
cantines ou peut-être pour une
incitation des communes
je pense que de toute façon nous allons
petit à petit progressivement vers de
plus en plus de bio d'ailleurs c'est ce
que nous avons fait dans le cas de notre
nouveau marché de restauration scolaire
ça fait partie des sujets que l'on
travaille aussi avec l'agglomération
j'avais demandé en tout début de mandat
qui a un travail commun pour que l'on
voit comment au niveau de des filières
d'approvisionnement alimentaire on
puisse mettre en place quelque chose au
niveau de cuisine centrale à l'échelle
de 50 ans en Yvelines donc nous y allons
et c'est une bonne chose je crois et ce
qui est au cours de votre mandat vous
avez été vous avez eu l'impression
d'être
comment dire d'être menacé physiquement
non jamais jamais jamais parce que
beaucoup de mer en quelques mères ont
été victimes effectivement d'agression
ou de menaces et enfin une dernière
question est-ce que vous êtes un maire
heureux ah oui complètement pleinement
merci Laurent mercière pour ces réponses
courtes vous avez joué le jeu en tout
cas ce soir je rappelle que vous êtes le
maire de Montigny-le-Bretonneux très
bonne année 2023 dans votre commune
merci à vous et très bonne année à
toutes et à tous merci à présent une
page sport dans ce 7 8
[Musique]
et Mickaël et le minero nous a rejoint
bonsoir journaliste sport de la
rédaction de TV 78 on va débuter cette
page port par du cyclisme c'était la
première compétition de l'année au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
ce week-end avait lieu les 6 heures du
vélo de route cette course d'endurance
organisée par la structure et le club
local de le CV les y78t programmé ce
samedi près de 100 participants répondus
présent pour ce rendez-vous des images
de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude ils sont
allés au bout de les forces samedi 14
janvier 96 pistards dont 16 féminines
ont participé à ses 6 heures du
Vélodrome national la compétition était
programmée pour la troisième fois sur la
piste 5 continents c'est une épreuve
d'endurance par équipe de trois ou
quatre coureurs qui se relaient qui se
relaient environ toutes les demi-heures
et le but du jeu c'est de faire le plus
grand nombre de tours possible dans
pendant 6 heures cinq catégories étaient
présentes sur la piste les coureurs
venus principalement de la région
francilienne et du s'employé pour être
le mieux classé sur cette compétition
amicale
vous avez déjà fait il y a trois quatre
ans en équipe 100% féminine et on
l'avait gagné je trouve ça sympa parce
que ça réunit toutes les catégories les
filles les gars et puis on vient on
prend du plaisir et ouais c'est plutôt
chouette je suis surprise à la première
fois que je le fais et c'est hyper dur
on essaie de mettre en place des
stratégies qui sont idéales pour que bah
pour jouer la gagne quoi on aura fait 6
heures ça va se jouer à deux tours près
quoi donc ça va être c'est tendu ce
rendez-vous d'ouvrez revenir l'année
prochaine au même date elle devrait donc
une nouvelle fois être la première
compétition de l'année au vélo et le
trône national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et on parle à présent Mickaël foot US
avec nos invités qui sont revenus en
plateau et oui c'est l'heure de la
reprise pour les Templiers d'Élancourt
les joueurs qui voulaient au complexe
sportif Europe à Élancourt débute leur
saison de deuxième division ce week-end
sur le terrain des Léopards de Rouen
pour nous en parler nous avons avec nous
sur ce plateau le capitaine Jordan de
brasse et Alix Wemba qui est
coordinateur défense bonsoir Monsieur
parce que je vous ai pas vu tout à
l'heure alors comment vous sentez-vous à
quelques jours de la reprise
quelques jours de la reprise pour nous
on a déjà repris depuis longtemps elle a
fait la prépa physique officielle la
reprise officielle bah comme je disais
tout à l'heure on est dans le bain on a
eu deux matchs amicaux c'est plus ou
moins bien passé en finit sur une
victoire on fait un petit match nul voir
comme c'était une opposition d'entente
donc ça va ça s'est bien passé aussi
on est dans le bain on est sur une bonne
dynamique
je pense que on attend tous le
championnat du football américain c'est
pour aller au match on a pas le choix et
on est tous impatient c'est vraiment ce
qui c'est vraiment ce qui nous anime là
c'est qu'on a un patient de reprendre en
tout cas au niveau de la confiance les
voyants sont ovaires sont au vert mais
c'est c'est pas une c'est pas une
conscience en fait c'est pas une
confiance qui est définitive c'est
surtout une envie c'est une pulsion
c'est un besoin en fait surtout ça vous
êtes impatients aussi dans des cours sur
le terrain si je peux dire moi c'est les
matchs qui me c'est les matchs qui me
motivent c'est les matchs qui me qui me
poussent et bah pour en revenir sur
notre confiance c'est surtout une année
où on arrive en début de championnat
sans trop de blessures on arrive
vraiment avec comment dire un bilan
médical qui est plutôt bon on a très peu
de joueurs blessés des joueurs qui ont
joué toute la saison dernière blessée
qui se sont bien reposées et qui se sont
bien soignés et là on revient en pleine
forme avec une bonne préparation
physique j'imagine c'est ça une bonne
préparation physique on a repris début
septembre on a poussé un petit peu avec
les équipes jeunes parce que on a
vraiment accentué sur la formation c'est
cette année donc on est plutôt pas mal
normalement comment vous trouvez ce
groupe le groupe est jeune il vit bien
on a eu quelques arrêts de fin de
carrière l'année dernière
ce groupe a quand même eu quelques
départs de part comme je disais la
formation dans des équipes de division
supérieures de première division donc on
a perdu quelques bons éléments
malheureusement c'est le jeu
heureusement pour nous parce que ça veut
dire qu'on fait du bon travail
malheureusement pour nous bah on perd
des éléments très importants mais le
groupe vit bien il est sain il y a eu un
peu de turn over au niveau de du côté
staff il y a eu un peu de temps 9h au
niveau des joueurs on a quelques
arrivées quelques départs tout ce qui
est basique dans le football américain
je sens qu'elle sont les qui sont les
nouveaux éléments est-ce que c'est ce
sont des jeunes des Templiers ce qu'il y
a des impôts US parce qu'on sait qu'il y
a des joueurs des États-Unis qui peuvent
venir aussi vous renforcer
par rapport aux saisons précédents
on avait pas mis l'accès sur sur les le
côté américain ce qu'on voulait vraiment
faire de la formation et rester en
interne maintenant quand on voit les
grosses écuries du championnat on voit
bien l'année dernière tour tous les
imports bah forcément
ça ça fait avancer donc oui il y a une
possibilité que que on se recroise sur
le plateau ou peut-être ailleurs où je
vous présente quelqu'un qui vient nous
aider pour le championnat et qui intègre
l'équipe peut-être dans les prochaines
heures aussi peut-être
Jordan
l'objectif aussi des Templiers
d'Élancourt c'est de former ses propres
jeunes et qui jouent après en équipe
Seigneur c'est bien ça ouais voilà c'est
ça déjà je suis bien placé pour le
savoir parce que je suis entraîneur de
la section
U17 donc des cadets vraiment le on est
un peu on est on a un club formateur on
est un club comment dire on a un peu les
Farmer c'est à dire que on forme
beaucoup de joueurs de très bons joueurs
qui ensuite partent soit dans de plus
hautes divisions ou soit vraiment à
l'étranger ils vont au Canada aux
États-Unis on a déjà eu pas mal
d'exemples comme ça et bah voilà nous
notre premier objectif c'est déjà formé
des joueurs pour notre notre équipe
première c'est ce qu'on fait avec les
U17 qui sont surclassés en U19 des U19
qui sont surclassés enseignants et
ensuite vraiment quand ils arrivent à un
âge où ils peuvent jouer enseignants ils
sont tout à fait intégrés dans dans
l'équipe senior et ils ont le même
niveau que qu'un senior de longue date
qui est là depuis trois quatre ans dans
le groupe quoi je sais pas s'il viendra
renforcer votre équipe on a une petite
séquence avec Michael et midoro regardez
qui avait testé le football américain
avec les Templiers d'Élancourt qui s'est
pris un gros plaquage dans lesquels il y
a quelques années il y a quelques années
j'avais testé voilà j'aurais pu jouer
peut-être apparemment receveur peut-être
Templiers est-ce qu'ils ont mis le
placage ils ont été peut-être sympa avec
vous Michael on va peut-être pleuvoir
alors je me souviens plus du nom du
joueur
ouais c'est ça
et ça va il va bien ben écoutez comme
disait Jordan tout à l'heure on est très
famille du coup les anciens joueurs
certains que vous avez vu dans la vidéo
dont moi qui était présent à l'époque le
jour où il a pris son sacré plaquage bah
en fait on est toujours investi dans le
club donc on dit surper va très très
bien c'est le directeur sportif
actuellement au club et comme disait
Jordan qui est aussi ancien joueur il
continue à jouer on est vraiment présent
on essaie de tout donner on essaie de
continuer à perdurer faire et faire
monter le club petit à petit cette
saison qui sera à l'extérieur qui sera
le weekend prochain face au léopard de
Rouen comment vous l'aborder cette
rencontre c'est du foot américain donc
nous on arrive sur le terrain toujours
avec un esprit de vainqueur on peut pas
arriver sur le terrain en se disant
voilà on va peut-être perdre le match
c'est pas du foot normal c'est pas du
soccer où on se dit il faut qu'on essaie
de pas perdre on arrive en disant on va
gagner tout simplement donc on aura
toujours l'objectif de gagner toujours
l'envie de gagner et après ce sera match
après match qu'on verra qu'on verra
comment ça se passe mais en tout cas
l'objectif le premier objectif c'est de
gagner le premier match c'est ça
quand on aborde l'état d'esprit quand on
aborde un match comme ça qui est le
premier de la saison on se retrouve à
l'extérieur on a pas le public on n'est
pas chez nous comme on dit il faut
arriver avec cette état d'esprit cette
envie de gagner bien sûr après le c'est
le terrain qui parle le score final nous
dira si c'est le bon état d'esprit ou
pas mais il faut avoir cette envie c'est
envie est présente et on est obligé d'y
aller de cette manière et justement vous
allez attendre ses preuves je pourrais
rétablir peut-être l'objectif de la
saison vous êtes en deuxième division et
2017 la deuxième division depuis 2017
comme vous l'avez bien vu bah il y a un
certain laps de temps de formation moi
qui ai joué à l'époque dans les dans
dans les équipes seniors et dans les
hautes équipes de
première division et autres
on est sur une phase de construction on
est sur une phase de recrutection en
fait qui prend son temps et elle est
pérenne elle est pérenne puisqu'on
arrive à rester justement dans cette
deuxième division on accède
régulièrement aux phase de playoff et je
pense que cet objectif doit être en
continu l'accession play-off et après
viser toujours plus haut l'année
dernière c'est ce qui nous est arrivé on
nous fait un bon parcours malgré 7 ou 8
blessés en un match qui nous a un peu
mal mis on finit par battre notre
concurrent direct qui est le repas de
Rouen qu'on recroise ce week-end et on
perd en playoff face au championnat 2e
division je pense que c'est un parcours
qu'on peut atteindre encore cette année
en tout cas on doit tendre à à aller
dans cette direction vous faites partie
favoris
favoris comment on dirait quand vous
avez quand vous êtes en deuxième
division et que vous êtes installé et
qu'une équipe descente première division
est-ce qu'il fait partie des favoris
d'accord pareil
je peux vous dire qu'on est une bonne
équipe de deuxième division et c'est le
terrain qui parlera ça c'est sûr et le
28 ça sera le premier match de la saison
à domicile ça sera contre les caïmans du
Mans pareil vous allez offrir un beau
spectacle vous supportez vous espérons
en tout cas on espère offrir le
calmement du mot qui monte au troisième
division il me semble champion voilà
champion de Détroit donc ils arrivent
avec les dents longues ça c'est sûr mais
qui va prendre au sérieux une équipe à
prendre au sérieux ils sont bien
construits ils ont mis le temps à monter
quand et là je pense que ils vont
arriver en fait plein de plein de bonnes
volonté et pareil dans les acquéreurs de
la même façon avec l'envie de gagner la
question rapidement un mot pour vous
adversaires qui vous regardent sûrement
à la télévision en ce moment bah les
adversaires on arrive
on arrive protégez-vous tout simplement
merci à vous deux en tout cas d'être
passé en Platon vous souhaite une très
bonne saison une très bonne saison à
2023 de foutues US rester avec nous
jusqu'à la fin on va passer avant au
reste de l'actualité sportive du weekend
il y avait du du soccer également soccer
dans le championnat de National de
soccer Versailles a continué ce weekend
sa bonne série et enchaîne une deuxième
victoire consécutive face à Avranches
ces jours de la cité royale se sont
imposés 3 à l'extérieur les buteurs
Versailles Thibault Jacques le
Néerlandais et Rachid Alioui en fin de
match avec cette victoire les versets
sont à la première place du classement
devant Martigues avec 32 points
engranger en 17 journée avec un mot de
tennis direction l'Australie l'Open
d'Australie avec une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour notre yvelinois Arthur
hinderknech le Saint-Germain lois c'est
incliné sèchement face aux qualifié
japonais Yusuke yatanuki en 1h43 le
score 6 3 6 3 6 2 pourtant 79 place
mondiales séparés les deux hommes Arthur
Riner a été le premier Français à
prendre la porte du côté de Melbourne il
a dit qu'il voulait débriefer sa défaite
avec son staff après une préparation
tronquée il est désormais numéro 4
français on parle de course automobile
avec la fin du Dakar le Dakar 2023 c'est
terminé sur une bonne note du côté de
livinois Jean-Pierre Garcin le copilote
originaire de Montesson a terminé une
très belle à 16e place avec le pilote
chinois wow you Zend il termine à plus
de 17h du vainqueur qatari n'a sert à la
tia Jean-Pierre Garcin visait un top 15
cette année lui est un à grand habitué
du Dakar avec 24 participations il
devrait revenir à l'année prochaine sur
le Dakar 2024 l'autre Illinois
Jean-Pierre strugo terminé à la 50e
place de la course sur MD rally sport on
revient dans les Yvelines avec du basket
à Poissy Poissy à basket continue
engranger les victoires les Yvelines
noires en tant que rangé une douzième
victoire dans le championnat de National
2 après leur victoire contre Vanves ce
week-end le score 68 à 52 à domicile ce
résultat permet au pisser d'être premier
à égalité avec un pays de Fougères on
écoute les réactions au micro de Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude on est pour l'instant
premier exo du championnat et notre
ambition bien sûr c'est d'être dans les
deux premiers en fin de saison pour
jouer les play-offs et pouvoir accéder à
la nationale une voilà donc l'ambition
est importante au niveau du
Julien Leroy
se qualifier et prendre du plaisir un
objectif majeur pour les participantes
cette nouvelle édition du championnat de
départemental de gymnastique artistique
féminine réunissait 21 clubs yvelinois
au gymnase Pierre de Coubertin de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les enjeux pour
elle c'est ce qualifier pour la suite
des compétitions c'est-à-dire pour
l'Inter départemental celle qui vont se
qualifier et pour les autres elles iront
en département en département 2 qui va
se situer à peu près vers le mois de
mars il y en a qui sont très fortes et
qui
bossent pour l'être il y a beaucoup
l'esprit de famille un rendez-vous
annuel pour les 350 participantes âgés
de 8 à 18 ans la gymnastique artistique
féminine permet assez sportive de
développer coordination force et
souplesse elles ont toutes normalement
le même niveau là c'est le département
donc c'est la première donc elle ne font
pas tout tout leur mouvement et au fur
et à mesure qu'on va monter dans l'année
jusqu'à la finalité là elles ont elles
vont tout envoyer leur mouvement
définitif on est pas mal sorti par
rapport à d'autres que l'année dernière
elles étaient plus fortes mais
dans cette année j'ai l'impression elles
doivent être tous stressées quatre des
six équipes de Montigny gym ont terminé
sur le podium lors de ce championnat la
médaille d'or a été décrochée une
satisfaction pour le club qui réalise
des résultats comparables à l'année
précédente
[Applaudissements]
un mot maintenant des Jeux olympiques de
2024 une thématique que vous avez traité
dans votre dernière émission si on
parlait sport spécial Jeux Olympiques
oui tout à fait Grégory et dans cette
émission nous avons parlé de golf avec
nos chroniqueurs vous le savez le Golf
National de 50 ans en Yvelines sur le
théâtre des épreuves de golf aux Jeux
olympiques de 2024 une discipline qui
est revenu aux JO de 2016 à Rio après
avoir été enlevé du programme après les
JO de 1904 pour nous en parler nous
avions avec nous en plateau le président
de la Fédération Française de Golf
Pascal Griso Philippe Pilato le
directeur du Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Alexandra
Bonetti joueuse professionnelle et
Arnaud courtier en charge des JO à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on va regarder
un extrait de cette émission les géo
seront-ils aussi grands que la Ryder Cup
2018 moi je suis partagé parce que alors
ça sera certainement pas aussi grand
pour les raisons énoncées par Pascal par
contre c'est la première fois que on va
vivre un événement en faisant partie
d'un ensemble et dans tout c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait il va y avoir sont les Jeux
Olympiques donc c'est extrêmement fort
et je pense que ça va être également une
force parce que ça va amener ça va
permettre de mettre peut-être en avant
également mais le site Le Golf National
le parcours le parcours le parcours le
parcours l'Albatros et je pense que pour
nous c'est une vraie force et je pense
que les JO ils vont être fort en terme
d'événementiel et fort en terme de
rencontre également donc voilà c'est
pour ça que je le placeerai à ce niveau
là et c'est une émission bien sûr à
retrouver en intégralité sur notre site
internet notre application mobile et sur
Youtube et bien évidemment il n'y aura
pas que le golf en 2024 pour ces JO non
bien sûr Grégory le département sera là
des secteurs les plus représentés
pendant les Jeux olympiques de 2024 à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y aura du
cyclisme sur piste au Vélodrome national
le BMX sur le Stadium de BMX juste à
côté il y aura aussi le VTT sur la
colline d'Élancourt le cyclisme sur
route devrait passer par 50 ans en
Yvelines La Valette Chevreuse et
Versailles Versailles qui va accueillir
une partie du marathon et les épreuves
d'équitation dans le parc du château il
y aura aussi du pentathlon moderne on a
déjà hâte d'y être
pourquoi pas le marathon pour tous oui
oui qui est ouvert à tout le monde mais
il faut avoir un certain niveau quand
même pour pour y participer merci
Michael pour toutes ces précisions
sportives je suis peut-être meilleures
sur le football américain comme vous
l'avez vu
j'avais une petite question justement
pour mes invités football américain ce
que vous avez déjà fait un calendrier au
Templiers sur le modèle des Dieux du
Stade est-ce que ça vous est déjà passé
par la tête
c'est une bonne idée après
il faut avoir les personnel
opérationnels et ok pour le faire
faut pas que ce soit il y a du gabarit
il y a du gabarit après ce serait bien
pourquoi pas faut pas oublier que il y a
les dieux du stade il y a aussi les
filles en rugby aussi qui l'ont fait
bien sûr on a une section de
cheerleadidia lui aussi ça a proposé
pourquoi pas par contre il y a des
calendriers photos qui sont déjà sortis
et qui ont déjà été publiés mais c'est
pas les types du stade
août 2024 pourquoi pas le rendez-vous
est pris en tout cas les invitation de
radio sensation le photographe frais de
Goudon qui est le photographe des Dieux
du stade à réaliser une série de clichés
des pompiers français et allemands il
est notamment allé à la rencontre et des
pompiers d'achats Facebook en Allemagne
une ville qui est jumelée avec
Saint-Germain-en-Laye de ce travail est
né une exposition itinérante qui sera
proposée dans les Yvelines à l'occasion
de la journée de l'amitié
franco-allemande ce sera le 22 janvier
prochain un projet né avec l'association
des Amis du jumelage
Saint-Germain-en-Laye achachenbourg et
avec le soutien et du fond citoyen
franco-allemand que nous présente
Corentin Alonso de nos confrères de
radio sensation
[Musique]
c'est une journée un peu particulière
pour la caserne d'achat finborg les
pompiers allemands vont poser
aujourd'hui devant l'appareil de Fredo
Fredo c'est le photographe des Dieux du
stade et de plein d'autres calendriers
il est spécialiste dans l'art de
photographier le corps des hommes
[Musique]
ça y est on rejoint Fred Goudon alors
Fred il y a besoin de quoi pour un
shooting alors il faut des flashs du
matériel qui est là et
puis tous les pompiers qui sont en train
de se mettre en place donc on a fait un
petit un petit discours de bienvenue ça
s'est bien passé et après ça on va
commencer à ajouter petit à petit les
uns après les autres individuellement
pour leur donner un petit peu l'idée de
ce que ça donne et puis pour moi aussi
avoir une idée de leur photogénie et
puis après on va enchaîner sur les
photos de groupe etc bon laisse prête se
préparer et puis nous on va aller mettre
une tenue un petit peu plus adaptée
[Musique]
ça y est maintenant on est dans le thème
c'est l'heure de la traditionnelle photo
de groupe
alors une belle photo de groupe
ouais c'est ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose ils font ils font corps on voit
que ils sont tous en place et en plus
ils se connaissent bien et donc je pense
que ça se ça se voit là mais ça se verra
encore plus à l'image
Corentin à toi maintenant à moi de jouer
[Musique]
est-ce que tout le monde est photo
génique non la photogénie c'est vraiment
ses propres à chacun et alors des fois
il y a des gens ils sont très beaux et
ils rentrent pas du tout à la photo et
puis des fois c'est l'inverse où les
gens sont un peu disgracieux peut-être
ou en tout cas et on dirait pas mais
quelquefois ça rend vraiment très très
bien à l'image donc peut-être que vous
me voyez là moi je suis très photogénose
vraiment faire ce shooting le
photographe est vraiment cool et nous
nous amusons beaucoup ensemble avec tout
le groupe les photos sont incroyables de
ce qu'on a déjà pu voir
au total ce sont près de 1500 photos qui
ont été prises aujourd'hui attends il va
falloir faire des choix et puis les
sélectionner pour pouvoir les exposer au
public prochainement en France
et l'exposition sera visible dans trois
lieux des Yvelines dès demain mardi à
l'hôtel de ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye à partir de 19h30
le lendemain mercredi 18 janvier
l'exposition sera toujours visible à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye mais à la Maison
de l'Europe rendez-vous des 10h30 et
enfin le 20 janvier à partir de 11h
l'exposition se déplacera au restaurant
Le crazyo la Montigny-le-Bretonneux
d'autres dates et lieu à venir pour en
savoir plus rendez-vous sur le site de
Radio sensation et on va refermer cette
émission en musique le vendredi 3
février prochain la memorise à trappe
accueille le concert de Skip The Use le
groupe de rock lillois fait son retour
sur scène après deux ans d'absence et
pour ouvrir la soirée la Pieta sera
également sur la scène de la Meuse
l'artiste est actuellement en tournée
pour la promotion de son dernier album
Lyna Mola attaque est sorti en novembre
la Pieta qui est avec nous en
visioconférence bonsoir
alors si on peut mettre le son en
plateau parce que je ne vous entends pas
juste pour commencer cette interview la
Pieta pour les téléspectateurs qui vous
connaissent pas quel est l'univers quel
est le style de la Pietà
alors nous avons un problème technique
nous entendons pas en plateau la Piéta
si vous pouvez peut-être activer votre
micro je ne sais pas si le micro est
désactivé
non visiblement un problème technique en
attendant peut-être en attendant de
régler ce problème on va jeter un coup
d'œil à la météo de demain on va voir si
on arrive à résoudre ce problème
technique dans un instant
[Musique]
et après la journée venteuse
d'aujourd'hui demain mardi dans les
Yvelines la pluie est toujours le froid
le matin des gouttes sont attendus sur
la partie nord et ouest du département
il fera 2 degrés dans l'après-midi il
devrait même y avoir de la pluie sur
tout le territoire et Vinois côté
température il fera 3 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Versailles 4
degrés à
4 degrés à Versailles 3 degrés pardon à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Rambouillet 4
degrés à Versailles ce mardi 17 janvier
nous fêterons les Roselyne on va voir si
on a réussi à retrouver la Pieta en
visioconférence et ce que on vous entend
est-ce que vous nous entendez vous nous
entendez ça je pense que oui et on va
voir si on vous entend
non malheureusement ne vous entend pas
alors je le disais on va on va regarder
tout de suite un extrait de votre
dernier album je disais un linamola
attaquer sorti en novembre on va écouter
un extrait de l'un des titres de cet
album c'est une tempête regardez
[Musique]
ça commence sûrement là c'est un peu
comme la vie ça bouleverse ce sera bon
mais ça reste joli je te tiens tu me
tiens ta vie en fait par les mots par
les mains quand tu rentres
le premier de mes deux pieds
[Musique]
voilà pour l'extrait d'une tempête je le
disais issue de votre dernier album la
Pieta qui est sorti en novembre dernier
c'est Lyna Morata visiblement nous avons
pas réussi à résoudre ce problème
technique on n'arrive pas à entendre la
Piéta je reprécise juste on aura
l'occasion de la réinviter d'ici le 3
février et le concert et le 3 février
donc on aura l'occasion de la réinviter
d'ici là pour régler ce problème
technique je reprécise juste que vous
serez sur la scène de la Meuse attrape
et vous ouvrirez la soirée le 3 février
prochain qui sera aussi animé par ce
type de use on peut d'ailleurs retrouver
un toutes les informations concernant la
billetterie voilà sur le site qui
s'affiche
kiosque.sqy.fr mais on ne vous invitera
d'ici là d'ici le 3 février pour venir
parler aussi de ce projet qui parle qui
mêle musique et littérature on aura
l'occasion d'en dire un peu plus lorsque
l'on aura résolu tous ces problèmes
techniques voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci de nous avoir suivi malgré ces
petits quacks techniques retour demain à
l'antenne sur TV 78 pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée
[Musique]